The technique of
derived variables
comes up in analyzing
state machines.
So let's just take a
quick look at it together.
So a derived variable
is simply a function
on the states of a state
machine that assigns some value
to the states.
So it's just that kind
of a function mapping.
If the values happen to be,
say, the non-negative integers,
it's called non-negative
integer value,
but it could be real
value, complex value,
and even take on other kinds
of odd kinds of values,
not necessarily numerical.
No pun there-- not odd
numbers, but unusual values.
So let's look at the example
of the robot on the grid.
The states were pairs of
non-negative integers giving
the coordinates of
where the robot was.
And one of the derived
variables that we
found was real
useful was the sum
value, sigma, of a state, which
is defined to be x plus y.
And this would be a
non-negative integer
valued derived variable.
So the word "derived" comes
because we're making it up.
It's not part of
the specification
of the state machine or
part of the program that
defines the state machine.
So in the robot example,
the actual states
were composed of the
two coordinates x and y,
but the derived
variable that we made up
was their sum of signal.
Another useful derived
variable for that robot example
was the parity of
sigma, whether or not
the number was even or odd.
So sigma is a 0,
1 valued variable,
which takes the value
0 if the sum is even
and 1 if the sum is odd.
So in the case of
fast exponentiation,
we looked at the
actual variable z,
which was part of the
invariant and a crucial part
of the program.
And what we noticed
about z was that z
was a strictly decreasing and
natural number valued variable.
As a matter of fact, we noticed
that it halved at each step.
But its values were
non-negative integers,
and it's strictly
decreasing at every step.
So that implies by the
Well Ordering Principle
that it will take
a minimum value.
And what we know about the
minimum value of a strictly
decreasing variable is that
the algorithm is stuck,
because once z has
reached its minimum value,
if the machine
took another step,
then it would get smaller.
So it means that the
algorithm has to terminate.
So this gives you a
general methodology
for proving termination-- find
a non-negative integer valued
strictly decreasing variable
guarantees the program stops.
As a matter of fact,
we can say sometimes
how long it will take
for the program to stop.
As we saw with fast
exponentiation,
it took not z, which
was the obvious bound,
but in fact, log of z,
because z not only went down
at every step, it got
halved at every step.
So in general, the concept of
a strictly decreasing variable
is one-- as shown here-- that
at every step of the state
machine, at each transition,
it gets strictly smaller.
A related idea is a weakly
decreasing variable.
These are not necessarily
useful for proving termination,
but they are often
useful, as you'll
see as we progress through
the term-- examples
where it helps you analyze
the behavior of the algorithm.
So a weakly decreasing
variable is one which goes down
or stays constant.
It never gets larger.
So if we looked at
the example of sigma,
the sum of the
coordinates, that's
up and down all over the place.
It's neither increasing
nor decreasing.
The other extreme is
the parity variable
pi, which was the 0 or
1 according to whether
or not the sum of the
coordinates was even or odd.
And pi is a constant,
and that means
that it's both weakly
increasing and weakly
decreasing in the
degenerate sense
that weakly increasing is
allowed to stay the same.
In fact, something is
weakly increasing and weakly
decreasing if and only
if it's a constant.
By the way, we used to call
weakly decreasing variables
"non-increasing," which is
the standard terminology
in the field.
In calculus, you talk about
non-increasing functions.
And we just found that it
caused a lot of confusion,
because you have to remember
that non-increasing is not
the same as not increasing.
So there's an example
of a function that
is not increasing, but it's
certainly not non-increasing.
And if that didn't register,
I'll let you think about it.
By the way, this method
of proving termination
by finding a strictly
decreasing natural number
valued variable generalizes
straightforwardly
to a variable which takes on
values from a well-ordered set
of real numbers.
Remember, a well-ordered
set of real numbers,
one of the definitions
of it is that it's
a set of numbers where
it's impossible to find
an infinite decreasing
sequence of values--
w0 less than w1 less than w2
less than w1 going on forever.
If that can't happen, then the
set is called well ordered.
Of course, the
non-negative integers
are the most obvious
basic case, but there
are a bunch of others
described in the notes.
And in general, the
termination principle
is that if you can find
a strictly decreasing
variable of derived variable
whose values always come
from a well-ordered
set, that also
is a way to prove termination.
That's going to guarantee
termination for the same reason
that the variable will have
to take a minimum value.
That's the other
definition of well ordered.
And when it does, the
machine can't move anymore.